Je me sens bizarre, à cause du développement tout ça
En grandissant je suis très très fatigué
vraiment paresseux
En grandissant je me sens plus fatigué alors
que je ne fais rien
En grandissant je me sens toujours petite mais en plus vieille
En grandissant, j'ai mal au jambes
Quand j'étais petite je ne mangeais pas beaucoup
alors que maintenant je mange
beaucoup parce que j'ai de plus en plus faim
Quand j'étais petit je mangeais des fourmis
et maintenant j'en mange plus.
hein?
Ben faut manger des fourmis, c'est pleins de protéines !
En devenant vieux, j'ai peur de perdre de
l'autonomie, et de ne plus recharger ma batterie
En devenant vieux j’ai peur de ne plus pouvoir faire un lancée souplesse
c’est quoi?
Avant je sautais partout, Maintenant je me retiens
Avant je bougeais tout le temps maintenant je préfère rester dans mon lit
Avant je savais tout juste marcher maintenant je peux courir mais j’ai pas envie.
J’ai envie de rien faire mais genre vraiment rien
Démarche traînante portée par des jambes
molles, filet de voix à la limite de l’extinction,
tête reposant à même la table pour ne pas
trop solliciter les cervicales,
l’ado est un être en permanence fatigué.
Il grandit, ce qui lui demande beaucoup
d’énergie, ses mouvements sont donc mou.
Quand 2 000 calories par jour suffisent
à un adulte , un adolescent doit avaler entre
3 000 et 3 500 calories.
Comme toute machine en mouvement, il a besoin d’énergie, il brûle donc plus de calories.
Il a du mal à s’endormir le soir à cause des hormones de croissance qui s’excitent en soirée.
Résultat : il passe du temps enfermé dans sa chambre, il s’endort tard le soir
Il paraît que ça peut durer cinq ans,
c’est bon à savoir.
En plus, il a la partie du cerveau qui
contrôle la motivation au ralenti.
Ce qui explique une grosse mollesse au niveau de l’enthousiasme.
En conclusion l’ado est mou, mais ce
n’est pas de sa faute.
Je suis là, au beau milieu.
Je me tiens là, avec au visage une impression d’absence
qui cloche beaucoup avec le reste.
Le présent s’enfuit de moi comme un vulgaire
liquide, ou plutôt coule à travers moi.
et la bouche dans l’histoire est bien la
seule à
rester close.
Alors je me tiens là, ouvre et ferme les
yeux pour faire le point, en dedans et en
dehors, et cela légèrement me fait tanguer,
la lumière qui rentre ou ne rentre plus et
dessine des mouvements.
On attend quelque chose de moi, je me trompe
?
on attend que je bouge? Figer le mouvement
n’est pas bien vu. Bouger où? Et où trouver
l’énergie nécessaire?
Pour l’heure, les pieds restent solidement
plantés ici. Mon torse se penche en avant,
doucement, comme en un léger déséquilibre.
Je sens couler le sang jusqu’à mes extrémités.
Et J’inspire l’air à pleins poumons Et
mon bras se soulève.
Et huit petits os se réveillent, situés
entre le bras et l’avant bras, les huit
petits os qui constituent la carpe. Je suis
un ensemble osseux à géométrie variable. Mes os s’articulent
entre eux, se mettent en action, en haut avec le radius et le ligament triangulaire, en
bas avec les cinq métacarpiens de la main.Mes muscles se relâchent, d’autres se décontractent
et provoquent des mouvements plus ou moins
coordonnés…
Flexion, extension,abduction adduction…
Je trace le chemin de mon mouvement intérieur
: cerveau, moëlle épinière, muscle...La
paume de ma main se rapproche de la face ventrale
de mon avant bras, puis la face dorsale de
ma main se rapproche de la face dorsale de
mon avant bras. paume main face ventrale avant
bras, face dorsale main face dorsale avant
bras paume main face ventrale avant bras, face dorsale main la face dorsale avant bras
paume main face ventrale avant bras, face dorsale main la face dorsale avant bras….
Imagine, Imagine un monde sans centrale au charbon,
Imagine un monde sans centrale nucléaire
Imagine que nous choisissions nos dépendances
énergétiques
Imagine que nous soyons responsables de ce
que nous dépensons en énergie
Imagine des énergies inépuisables, renouvelable
Imagine un monde dans lequel chaque mouvement
de la nature nous permettrait de
recharger nos batteries!
Imagine, y’a des gens qui ont créé une
maison totalement autonome en énergie
juste le soleil, le vent, la terre, l’eau
Imagine, être dépendant juste des éléments
il y a le ciel, le soleil et la mer...
Imagine même que chacun de nos mouvements
marcher
courir
pédaler
danser, se tourner les pouces? claquer des doigts, nager
sauter, tapoter la table? dévaler les escalier, jouer de la batterie
monter les escalier
tout ça produit de l’énergie
Imagine toute ce qu’on produit en énergie
juste en bougeant
Imagine toute cette énergie qui se perd et
s’éparpille dans l’espace!
Imagine tout ce que nous pourrions faire si on arrivait à la récupérer!
Imagine, des trottoirs qui récupèrent l’énergie des passants
énergie cinétique transformée en énergie électrique
Imagine les jours de manif, tu peux éclairer toute la ville
ça existe déjà, des trottoirs connectés aux lampadaires
j’ai lu un article, il disait ça
à Toulouse, la ville a installé des capteurs Et parait même qu’ils vont faire pareil avec les marelles, tu sais dans les cours d’école
si si c’est vrai.
Imagine un stade de foot
Imagine si on pouvait transformer la course des joueurs en énergie
On pourrait éclairer tout le stade
Imagine le nombre de joueurs multiplié par le nombre de match
Imagine une coupe du monde, Multiplié par le nombre de pas
Si chaque pas produit, disons 7 watt, t’imagine!?
Imagine même qu’on puisse récupérer toute l’énergie des supporters
TOUT, tu récupères TOUT
et juste avec les jambes de footballeur, t’éclaire
tout Toulouse, Pourquoi Toulouse ? Pourquoi pas...
Tu peux dire que je suis un rêveur,
You may say I'm a dreamer,
Mais je ne suis pas le seul,
But I'm not the only one,
J'espère qu'un jour tu nous rejoindras,
I hope some day you'll join us,
Bah, ça existe déjà, les terrains de foot connectés aux lampadaires
j’ai lu un article, il disait ça en 2014,
à Rio, dans le stade d’une favela
et en 2013, les champs Elysées étaient recouverts de plaques pour récupérer l’énergie des marathoniens
You may say I'm a dreamer,
Tu peux dire que je suis un rêveur,
But I'm not the only one,
Mais je ne suis pas le seul,
I hope some day you'll join us,
J'espère qu'un jour tu nous rejoindras,
And the world will live as one.
Et que le monde vivra uni.